Digamos que tenemos la ecuación lineal y = ½x - 3.
Si quisiéramos dibujar la recta que representa el
conjunto de puntos donde los valores de sus
coordenadas x y y satisfacen esta ecuación,
podríamos empezar dibujando en el plano
algunos de esos puntos y unirlos con una recta,
porque esta ecuación está representada en el
plano con una recta. Hagamos una tabla para
los valores de x y y, y lo que vamos a hacer
es dar algunos valores de x para obtener los
valores de y. ¿Qué pasa si decimos que el valor
de x es 0? Entonces tendremos que ½ por 0 es 0,
y nos queda -3, entonces y sería -3. Ahora
bien, aquí tenemos ½, así que multipliquemos
por cosas que sean múltiplos de 2 para que sea
más fácil calcular el valor de y. Por ejemplo,
¿qué pasa si x es 2? Si x es 2, 2 • ½ es 1 y 1 - 3
es -2. Muy bien, ahora veamos qué pasa si x es 4:
4 / 2 es 2 - 3 es -1, y de hecho ya con esos
puntos es suficiente para dibujar una recta. En
realidad, para dibujar una recta sólo necesitamos
dos puntos. Muy bien, entonces vamos a graficar
estos puntos en el plano coordenado que tenemos
aquí. El primero de ellos es 0 - 3, entonces
corresponde a este punto que tenemos aquí; el
siguiente es 2 - 2, que corresponde a este otro
punto que tenemos aquí, y también tenemos 4 - 1,
que es este otro punto. Ahora, nosotros podríamos
intentar dibujar la recta simplemente uniendo
esos puntos, y más o menos se vería algo así,
más o menos de esta forma, muy bien y ahí tenemos
la gráfica o la recta que representa esta ecuación
lineal. Entonces vamos a escribirlo: esta es
la gráfica de la ecuación y = ½x - 3. Ahora
que ya tenemos esta gráfica, cuando vemos
una gráfica de este estilo es interesante
ver dónde interseca los ejes, entonces primero
tratemos de ver la intersección con el eje x,
que es el eje horizontal. Podemos observar que
esa intersección se encuentra en este punto,
esta es la intersección con el eje x, y a este
punto en particular se le conoce como abscisa
al origen, esta es la abscisa al origen, y, por
supuesto, la coordenada es 6,0. Entonces, siempre
que veamos una recta que interseca al eje x el
punto donde el interseca se conoce como abscisa
al origen. En este caso la coordenada es 6,0, y
por supuesto que la coordenada y es 0, justamente
porque estamos sobre el eje x o el eje de las
abscisas, como también se le conoce al eje x,
y por eso es que este punto lleva ese nombre. Muy
bien, ahora podríamos preguntarnos ¿en qué punto
interseca esta recta al eje y? Y podemos observar
que este es el punto donde interseca al eje,
y de hecho aquí está en la tabla. Cuando x es 0
nos encontramos sobre el eje y, el eje vertical,
en el punto -3 sobre el eje y, y entonces a
este punto se le conoce como ordenada al origen,
porque al eje y también se le conoce como el eje
de las ordenadas, y este punto es 0, -3. Muy bien,
ahí tenemos tanto la abscisa como la ordenada
al origen. Ahora bien, este punto también lo
podríamos verificar en nuestra ecuación. Veamos:
cuando x vale 0, entonces tenemos que y vale -3,
el otro punto sería cuando y vale 0, entonces
cuando y vale 0 tenemos que ½x - 3 es 0, es decir,
necesitamos un valor de x que al dividirlo entre
2 y restarle 3 nos dé 0, por lo que si x vale 6
al dividirlo entre 2 es 3 y al restarle 3 nos da
0. Entonces estos dos puntos los podemos verificar
directamente en nuestra ecuación lineal. Muy
bien, ahora que ya sabes cómo se encuentran
las ordenadas y la abscisa al origen, vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo. Digamos que tenemos ahora
la ecuación lineal 5x + 6y = 30. Como siempre
te invito a que hagas una pausa y trates de
hallar por tu cuenta la ordenada y la abscisa al
origen de la gráfica que describe esta ecuación,
que de hecho es una recta. Vamos a hacerlo juntos,
vamos a comenzar haciendo nuestra tabla. Bien,
pongamos una tabla donde tengamos los valores de
x y los valores de y. Ahora, si nosotros queremos
encontrar la ordenada al origen necesitamos
que el valor de x sea 0, entonces si x vale 0
este término es 0. Y ahora nos preguntamos ¿qué
valor de y al multiplicarlo por 6 nos da 30?,
y el valor de y que al multiplicarlo por 6 nos da
30 es 5, entonces y vale 5. Y si ahora queremos
encontrar la abscisa al origen, eso es cuando
y vale 0, entonces este término es igual a 0,
y nos preguntamos ¿qué valor de x al multiplicarlo
por 5 nos da 30? Entonces vemos que si y vale 0,
entonces x tendrá que ser 6, porque 6 • 5
es 30. Ya podemos graficar estos puntos:
tenemos el 0,5 que se encuentra aquí, y tenemos el
6,0, que coincide con este otro punto de la recta,
y nosotros queremos dibujar la recta que pasa por
estos dos puntos, podríamos hacer algo así y luego
así para dibujar el otro lado, más o menos. Y ahí
tenemos la gráfica de la recta que satisface esta
ecuación, y simplemente necesitábamos dos puntos:
el primero de ellos es la ordenada al origen,
cuyas coordenadas son 0,5, este de aquí
es el punto de la ordenada al origen,
y podemos observar que también este punto, el
6,0, coincide con la abscisa al origen. Muy bien,
ahí tenemos otro ejemplo más de cómo
encontrar las intersecciones con los ejes.